This is the biggest question that most women ask.
How do I transition financially?
How do I get out from underneath my husband
if he's been a sole provider for all these years?
You're gonna have to play his ass.
There's no cute way to put it.
You're gonna have to pretend.
And when you're like, I cannot do this any longer,
you kind of switch into, like,
I feel like it's your last reserves of energy.
And that's what you're gonna finally,
finally fucking take from.
You're gonna click into, like,
Ultra fucking good girl mode.
You're gonna be the little fucking princess, like.
Like if you guys just got married yesterday,
he's gonna be shocked at how you have transformed
into the perfect fucking wife.
Everything is. Oh,
my god, you're right.
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry, honey.
You know, we're gonna fix everything.
That's it. He's right about everything.
I'm sorry is the answer to every fucking thing.
Because you're gonna be asking more of him than you normally do.
Because you're gonna ask him to be paying for a course,
a class A, whatever the fuck you need to do,
because it does take some initiative on your part.
You're gonna have to look at your life
and what you could fucking piece together.
How could you live? Where could you?
You're gonna have to imagine he's dead.
Imagine what your life is gonna look like.
Budget that shit out, okay?
Rent is probably gonna Be about.
I could probably live in that apartment complex over there,
or I could live with my sister over here.
Whatever the fuck. It's your life.
You're gonna have to put those pieces together,
and then you're gonna know how much money you need.
Now, you're gonna know what kind of job you need.
You can either get a.
If your kids are old enough and you can work while they're in school,
boom, right there.
Just get a job if they're not.
You gotta get creative. You could either start your own business,
take a couple. Because anything you do,
you're gonna have to take a little bit of time to work up.
You can start a business
like a cleaning business or a cooking business or anything where you.
You get to set the price for.
I need to work this many hours.
This is how much money I need to make per hour,
and this is when I can do it.
Do you know what I mean? Like,
it's basically time that you take off the stay at home mom hat
and put on the, like,
I'm the leader of my family now,
because that's what you're gonna be.
So you take complete fucking control of your life.
And the only way to do that is to really play the little good girl.
Play his ass. Let him think you're playing along.
You're doing all the things he wants you to do,
but in reality, you're Just getting him to support what you need to do
so you could get on your feet.
Cause he's gonna be suspicious.
He's gonna be like, why the fuck?
All of a sudden she wants school?
Or all of a sudden she wants this?
You just keep sucking his dick to silence so that he shuts the fuck up.
You could get your shit shit straight
and then leave him when it's time to leave him,
you know what I mean? In that time,
you're gonna. You just.
You tune him out. Do you know what I mean?
Just so that you, you know,
you have the. The end is in sight.
So it's much easier to play good girl now.
Do you know what I mean? So
that is my deepest advice to you
when you're trying to transition financially
and get out and get on your own feet.
And I am sending you all the love and,
oof, like so much love and encouragement that you make it out.